Behind this mirage, this illusion, there was a master manipulator,
a serial cheater, and a predator.
Angler fish, dude. Angler fish. But then I find out you've had
a girlfriend this entire time. Do you realize how bad it is?
Oh, you son of a You son of a [__] Oh, that girl's
destroyed.
Guys, 6:00 a.m. today, we've got exposing Sykkuno, a serial cheater,
master manipulator, and dangerous predator. They dropped a full
Google Doc. Okay? This has been out for about 12 hours, 13 hours
now, 20.4 million views. Now, if you guys weren't here earlier
when I talked about it, I have like some sort of burning rage,
some sort of burning hatred for Sykkuno that I can't explain.
It is irrational. I just hate this guy. I've always hated this
guy. From the first moment I heard his voice, I didn't even know
what he looked like, I hated him. I heard his voice, I was like,
"Oh, I I find this guy very off-putting, okay? The way he communicates,
the way he acts nice, but he could like There's something underlying
it. It's very uncanny valley. It was upsetting to me, okay?"
Then I saw his face. And I hated this even more, okay? And it's
totally irrational, and I would never argue that he was a bad
person, but I just hated this guy irrationally.
And And now today, when this dropped, my reaction was just like,
"Let's go."
I don't know why. I still can't justify it. So, I'm hoping this
person gives me a little bit of a way
to justify it, all right? We've got a full Google Doc here. It's
32 pages, but we also have this Mujin video, and I think this
person worked with Mujin. If you guys remember, we watched a
I think it was the Kaede 10s documentary that Mujin did, okay?
We watched that a couple weeks ago. So, I think we're going to
use this video as like our reading of the Google Doc and stuff,
because it it also just includes a bunch of [__]
in it. There's a whole video of basically Sykkuno confessing,
I guess, to the things that are said in here. I do believe most
of the allegations are things like love bombing, okay? But there's
a full a full YouTube video.
I've been told it is very funny, okay? Let's get into it. >> of
4 years has recently become obsessed with a male streamer, and
I feel really uncomfortable about it. This was a post made on
the subreddit r/ So, my girlfriend and I have lived together
for 2 years now, and it's great. My girlfriend lost her job back
in July, thanks to you know what, and it has really devastated
her. She started panicking about finding another job in this
market. I'm really fortunate to have a well-paying essential
job and my partner's dead. So, I was more than happy to let her
have a break for a few months. She really stepped up, and the
apartment was super clean, and she was making delicious elaborate
dinners. The punchline here is she started watching Sykkuno's
streams, okay?
around the end of 2020. What was particularly shocking here is
that barely just a few days after making that initial post, he'd
end up breaking up with his girlfriend. Her obsession with that
streamer was that irrational. And during that time, she wasn't
the only one who might have felt this way. That's because the
male streamer in question here was none other than Sykkuno. And
Dude, somebody linked a picture of this guy without the makeup
on and [__] and before like the skin care or whatever
he did, dude, this guy this guy looked totally different, all
right? This guy had like a glow-up like I've never seen before.
It's crazy. >> name and face that had become a core memory
of the COVID-19 pandemic, more specifically when everyone was
locked up in their homes. In the span of less than a year, he
would go from having 1,000 average viewers on Twitch to 50,000,
even having a streamer he peaked over
concurrent viewers. What he'd be most known for was his gameplay
of Among Us with his friends who happened to be very big content
creators as well. Not only would he get tens of thousands of
concurrent viewers on Twitch, but he would get millions upon
millions of views on his YouTube channel as well. And while his
rise to fame is definitely incredibly impressive, what was truly
unparalleled here is his extremely high ratio of female viewers,
confirmed to having been higher than any of his other content
creator friends.
This guy had mad You're telling me this guy had mad tits. One
of these girls cheated on her boyfriend, cheated on the Abe guy,
right? Which one is it? Which one is it? Who's the cheater? Which
one? Does everybody in OTV cheat? Is this just a thing? If you're
in OTV, you're a cheater or you get cheated on? Wait, they they
all cheat? Okay. Uh What's What's the deal with the OTV people?
They're all like the nicest people, but actually they're super
catty and cheating [__] What the heck? Except Lily.
Except Lily.
His handsome look, his anime-sounding voice, and his witty jokes
made women go rabid. In fact, there was also a joke that he would
turn male fans gay. But what made him really desirable is just
how socially awkward he was. He was innocent in an endearing
way. He was a boy failure that needed a woman to fix him. In
a nutshell, he was this picture.
I'm sorry.
This is the issue with Sykkuno is he's like an angler fish, okay?
This This was so obviously manufactured the whole time. That's
what seems sinister is you could just tell this is like the lure,
right? This is not a real person. He's like an angler fish. Yeah.
It's Somebody compared him to Emiru just in the glow-up and like
how he looks without the makeup, but also just in terms of like
what he provides, it's like I know that this whole thing is a
presentation. It's just all totally fake.
And it really throws me off. allergic
to other women. He just couldn't handle anything romantic. He
would get too flustered. This made many of his fans want to be
the one to finally fix him. But make no mistake here. This was
all a perfectly crafted image that he had made for himself. He
wanted you to think that he was innocent, naive, a boy failure,
someone who's inexperienced in relationships and would never
hurt a fly. Because in reality, behind this mirage, this illusion,
there was a master manipulator, a serial cheater, and a predator.
Someone who would make it a point for many years to target smaller
content creators I mean, that's all totally expect I'm sorry,
that's all totally expected. for it, because he admits to everything
in a recorded voice call with the victim herself. And on top
of that, that same victim who goes by the name of hemmamalvt,
would choose to write a Google Doc that shows the entire timeline,
her and Sykkuno's DMs together, as well as the DMs of another
victim that actually slept with Sykkuno while being totally oblivious
to the fact that he has been in a relationship since 20 Okay.
Now, while I do think cheating is bad, obviously, I trust me,
I'm not one of these like losers who tries to argue cheating's
fine. Everybody cheats, so it's okay.
No. No. No, that's not an argument you would accept anywhere
else. It's not an argument you ever should accept. It's like
you shouldn't be shocked that people do cheat, but cheating is
bad. Obviously, okay? But to call these people like victims because
they had sex with this guy that they like adored him or massive
fans of, and he was cheating on his girlfriend, you're not a
victim in that case. Maybe you could be like a victim of lying,
the the duped,
okay? But like victim, I feel like victim's pretty specific language
that you should leave for people who are victims of something
more nefarious, okay? 21. All right, so first off, who the hell
is Sykkuno? Well, before starting his streaming career, he actually
used to be a software engineer working in the Bay Area of California.
His monotonous office life would change forever, though, when
he would meet LilyPichu, a well-known content creator who actually
started making content as far back as 2012.
However, when they met, she was far from being the very well-known
content creator that we know today. It was back during the Season
3 World Championship for League of Legends during the year of
2013, so barely a year into her content creator journey. Sykkuno
would be aware of her content. He'd reach out to her and would
want to meet her, seeing that they're both at the same place.
LilyPichu agreed, thinking, "Oh, am I about to meet a fan? That's
awesome." She'd be absolutely shocked when that fan would show
up with a massive bouquet of flowers. As she was about to thank
him, he Oh, no! He actually was the loser at SOME POINT. OH,
NO!
"COULD I MEET YOU?" AND HE COMES WITH A huge bouquet of flowers.
"I I booked us a reservation." No! No! Although, maybe it's possible
so he's got like the the stuff over his dude. This is This is
like a racist censoring. I'm going to be honest with you. It's
like overtly racist censoring. But
is it possible
that he was just being nice? I don't know. I >> would run
away back to his cousins. According to him, these were his only
friends at the time. He was that lonely. He was simply too embarrassed
to interact with her further. As she would start her streaming
journey, she'd play with her friends, and one of those friends
would be Sykkuno. Her viewers would start to express interest
in him, especially seeing that his voice sounded like an anime
character. There was genuine demand in her community to know
what he looked like. What they didn't know, though, was that
LilyPichu had already shown him. He was there with her when she
went to Summoners Con in 2015, and he was right there with her
in her vlog. That hairline is rough. That is a rough hairline
right there. But most of her community were simply not aware
of this. So, seeing that there was growing demand to see what
he looked like, they decided to do a face reveal live on LilyPichu's
stream around the year of 2019. Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're such
a Oh, okay, here we go.
Uh yeah, he's got He's definitely wearing makeup in like all
of his video He wears a lot of makeup. He does like the whole
K-pop makeup thing. Like his skin's not [__] up here
at all. He just wears a [__] ton of makeup. >> Wait,
you're actually so much braver than I thought. Only cuz you're
That See, that's why I hate this guy. That right there, that
I It was comments LIKE THAT WHERE I'M JUST LIKE, HOLY I hate
this person. Holy Holy holy
That That was like exactly. I don't even feel bad. I DON'T EVEN
FEEL BAD FOR hating this guy anymore. Right there.
Uh Wait, you're actually so much braver than I thought. Only
cuz you're here.
All right, I'm going to say
BUT HE THOUGHT HE'S NOT JOKING. He talks like that all the time.
He does that all the time. I don't think he's joking. I seriously
don't.
All right, cringe. >> Unless Unless you actually believe
it. Unless you actually want that. All right, cringe. Unless
you want it. Unless you want it Unless you're >> definitely
not disappointed. In fact, LilyPichu had such an impact on Sykkuno
that she would be, well, the main reason why he would start streaming.
And you can hear him say that himself. So, what what convinced
you to start streaming?
Uh Lily, actually. And speaking of streaming, he would start
doing so shortly after revealing his face on LilyPichu's stream.
He'd start in the beginning of 2019 with barely under 100 viewers.
But as the months would go by, he would start to get very rapid
growth. He would really start putting in serious hours by August
2019. And within just 1 year, by August 2020, he'd be sitting
at 8,000
average viewers, reaching a peak of 15,000.
But how? Why? He would start to play the game Among Us with some
of the biggest content creators on the planet. And within just
4 months, he would go from 8,000 average viewers all the way
up to
average viewers, peaking at 100,000 viewers in one stream. He
was gaining half a million followers every single >> man.
In 2023, for an April Fools' joke, he would debut his first VTuber
model. Oh, no. Does he have the Bernie Sanders bit in here? Extending
his reach to new >> You guys remember that Bernie Sanders
Let's go. The reason I'm mentioning
this is because at some point, he was invited to a call with
the Help save democracy. It is. IT IS PROGRESSIVE VICTORY. PROGRESSIVE
victory paid for Sykkuno to meet Bernie Sanders as a VTuber.
I forgot Well, I didn't forget about this. I actually remembered
it cuz it's seared into my brain. Bernie Sanders alongside Valkyrae
and Pokimane. And instead of showing his face, he chose to be
a VTuber. This was so ridiculous and it went so viral that he
inadvertently kind of became a spokesperson for VTubing in one
stream. You see, back in 2023, Pokimane would make the very interesting
revelation that Sykkuno had the highest female demographic fan
base compared to any other streamer, her included. She would
compare his level of fame and the way his fans acted towards
him to K-pop idols. He simply wasn't seen like the run-of-the-mill
Twitch streamer. Does he He totally built up that persona. That's
literally what he wanted for himself, >> No, there was
Has to be a wig. It is definitely a wig. definitely more to this.
And one of the main reasons why this worked out so well is because
he was seen as a boy failure. No, not the kind of guy who's unemployed
and lives in a dump and smells like [__] I'm talking
about the ideal boy failure. The guy who's handsome, smells nice,
doesn't live in a dump, but is instead just a hopeless romantic.
Someone who turns all red when you want to initiate physical
contact. The most innocent, naive soul imaginable. The appeal
of a boy failure isn't necessarily that he's a failure. It's
the fact that he's perfect, but just needs one person to fix
him. And that's how a significant chunk of his fan base felt.
If you watched my channel before, then it's not too different
from a girl failure that has a male audience that wants to fix
her. It's the same parasocial mess. This can be very easily seen
in some of the most viral fan-made videos of Sykkuno, like this
one, for example, sitting at over 3 million
Nelson Derek? No, it's not Nelson Derek. So, it's not >> Sykkuno
tells his trauma about girls. Sykkuno trusts his friend Disguised
Toast more than the girls. So, this guy had barely any romantic
experience, and yet still, he had his heart broken. He needs
a woman that will fix him and tell him it'll be okay. And maybe
she'll be one of his fans. If only he knew how handsome and amazingly
desirable he was, though. Because here's another fan-made video.
Everyone's simping for Sykkuno because who doesn't? I mean, God,
if only he wasn't a boy failure. >> Dude, dude, dude. How
are Dude, if any guys watch this stream, that's how you know
no dudes watch this stream. If any dude watch this stream, they
go, "That's a predator." They clock that [__] in
0 seconds flat. That's predator. I feel I I had that feeling
instantly. Not predator, necessarily. I was just like, "I hate
this guy. This guy's disturbing. This guy is gross. Something
Something's wrong. Something's off." So, I feel like there's
a There's a feel I've got a feeling, okay? It's just immediately,
the hairs on the back of my neck rise up. I'm just like, "Dude,
this this is off. There's something weird here, okay?" And
And I think any guy who watched his content for like any extended
period of time, more than like a few hours, would go, "Yeah,
I know. This guy's a This guy's predator. This guy's like doing
this explicitly for women to try to get women to message him."
For sure. 100%.
Uh guys, I just really Disguised Toast, I just I can't really
talk to girls. I don't really know how to talk to girls.
Could you give me some tips for talking to girls? I just I mean,
kind of scare me, and I don't know how to approach them. And
so, like, unless women message me, I really can't do much. I
dude, 100%. >> failure and understood how smooth he was
with women, but he's too naive. Because guess what? This video,
sitting at over 4 million views, is titled Sykkuno being smooth
with girls for 14 minutes. Yeah, I think you get the point by
now, right? This image of him that was so carefully crafted would
attract a very large female audience. It would also allow him
to be one of the only male streamers to constantly be able to
hang out with a majoritarily female friend group without him
or them getting in trouble. By the
they're lucky this guy didn't do assault cuz I will say
they all are Women Women see this, okay? This is the how women
think. Oh, this guy's hanging out with this woman and this woman
and this woman and this woman, and they're not treating him like
a dangerous
That means he's totally safe. That means he's totally safe to
talk to. Yep, that means he's totally safe. He would never do
If this guy had done anything violent, holy These women would
all There'd be hell to pay, okay? Thank God he was just a
Thank God he wasn't doing anything like that, all right? The
guy was innocent, allergic to love, and he wouldn't hurt a single
fly. This allowed him to do things that other male content creators
could never do. Like, dude, this is him sniffing the armpit of
Fuslie at some point during a podcast when they were talking
about body odor. This is how much he was trusted around women.
And even though his audience was very obsessed over him, they
saw him as so Uh-huh. Yeah. He's like He's like gained all of
the advantages
of being a gay best friend when he's not gay. He's straight.
And But he's gained every single advantage of the gay best friend.
But he's openly straight. So, all of the other women who are
seeing the gay best friend that's openly straight and just can't
find the right woman, yeah, of course they're all in the DMs.
Of course they're all in the DMs. However, his viewer count would
slowly begin to drift. And by April 2026, he'd be sitting at
1,665
average viewers, a far cry from the peak of the pandemic back
at 50,000. As far as content creator careers go, this really
wasn't so bad. The guy was a multimillionaire. What people weren't
aware of, though, is that for many years since becoming a viral
sensation, he would use his status as Sykkuno, as the most desirable
streamer imaginable, as this K-pop idol. A lot of these arguments
do apply to people who do like who basically just are like groupies,
Like, that's that's what it is.
And it's weird how we're acting like as a society, people didn't
just like broadly were fine People were just broadly fine with
this. There's jokes about it. There's media about it. Like, nobody
had that big an issue with it, it feels like, for a very long
time.
So, it's like weird that we now rewrite it to like, "Oh, well,
this is clearly wrong." Now, maybe there's a lot more in terms
of the behavior here that is way worse. I will say
one weird thing is is he's 34 acting like this. He is like old.
He is like 34, 35 now. He is like way older than you would expect
for acting the way he does, okay? to pursue relationships with
smaller or up-and-coming content creators, whether they be cosplayers
or VTubers, manipulating them into thinking that they were special
on the hopes of hooking up with them and while being in a monogamous
relationship. This is the real Sykkuno. And now, we finally have
Hbomber VT, who I'll refer to as Mal from now on, is someone
who has been making content for the last year. She occasionally
streams from time to time, but also tends to post cosplays on
her Twitter profile, some of them being revealing. Those revealing
cosplays would catch Sykkuno's attention, and he'd follow her
on Valentine's Day of 2026. Within barely a few days, he would
start talking about how they should move in together into the
same house, all while having a girlfriend. When Mal would find
out about the girlfriend, she would decide to write a Google
document. The Google document would contain Mal's side of the
story, as well as Elfiye Lea's side of the story, another VTuber
who, of course, also posts cosplays from time to time, which
is why Sykkuno was interested in her to begin with. She
Oh, that's very interesting, too. I Dude, that's That's very
interesting.
I feel like that's a sort of And listen, it's not it's not to
say it's like evil he needs to go to jail, but I do feel like
you target VTubers
because of some sort of insecurity.
You know what I'm saying? Like, a VTuber who will is willing
to post like the perfect pictures of herself,
So, I know she's like not I know she's like kind of attractive,
but also
insecure. She doesn't want to stream her own face at all this
Yeah. So, I had no idea Sykkuno had a girlfriend. >> And
he would meet up with him during December 2025 in Paris when
he would travel for a convention. Unlike Mal, though, she would
actually end up sleeping with Sykkuno. Again, completely oblivious
that he has a girlfriend. They would both share their stories
in the DMs with Sykkuno in the Google document. This document
would be 32 pages long, and it would detail both of their experiences
with Sykkuno, leading up to the revelation of the fact that he
has a girlfriend as well as a link to the full 70-minute YouTube
video in which Mal would confront Sykkuno about cheating on his
girlfriend with her. Here's how it start off. This is the Alfie
Layla girl. So, this is the Alfie Layla girl again? Sykkuno is
not the kind s- And this is the Hemmal girl, okay? Hemmal right
here. soft-spoken character you see on stream. He is a serial
cheater, liar, and manipulator who uses his status to get what
he wants from as many women as possible. More specifically, ones
who are smaller or up-and-coming content creators knowing that
he can take advantage of them. After confiding in many others
that have had similar experiences with Sykkuno, I realized that
this was not an isolated incident. In fact, it was something
that had been going on for multiple years. He always made sure
to cover his tracks and never left a paper trail significant
enough for someone to make this public, but I kind of doubt that.
I kind of doubt that, but hey, we'll keep we'll keep >> changed.
These are serious allegations, and I fully understand that this
should not be treated lightly. I urge all other content creators
who have been personally affected by Sykkuno's behavior to not
remain silent as I believe that there is strength in numbers.
This document will not only include proof from me, but from another
victim who has given me her consent as well. Below, you will
find evidence that will expose his calculated pattern of love
bombing and manipulation, as well as a recording of a voice call
where he explicitly admits to all his wrongdoings. So, what I'm
looking for here is him misrepresenting his intentions, okay?
Like yes, if he's if he's talking to this girl like he was going
to be in love with her, I'm going to we're going to buy a cat,
move in together, right? Just for and then he like cuts coms
like immediately after or something. Like what I would say knowing
that he has a girlfriend or he has a long-term relationship,
right?
that's like not okay. I would say I don't know if that's predation.
It's like really dishonor- it's really [__] up for
his girlfriend. It's lying. I don't know if it rises to predation
in the same way. The next section of the document would be titled
our first conversation. After Valentine's Day, I was so excited
about him following me that I told a friend who then urged me
to strike up a conversation. I finally worked up the courage
to send him a DM and he replied right away. So, here we can see
on the 15th of February, Mal would send, "Are you still looking
for a Valentine's Day, perhaps?" To which Sykkuno would say so
innocently, "What? You can't just open up with something like
that. And besides, Valentine's Day is almost over where I'm from
already." To which she would reply with, "I mean, we can always
do a Valentine's Day do-over, you know?" Mal would continue by
saying, "Things started out innocently enough with him inquiring
about fun things to do near where I live, such as aquariums and
conventions, TwitchCon EU specifically. He not once expressed
to me any discomfort or that he wasn't single." So yeah, this
is how it goes. If someone expresses interest in you, right?
You typically tell them fairly quickly that you're already in
a committed relationship. You don't just let things slide. Mal
had no reason to think Well, if you're that's if you're in a
committed relationship.
Is he allowed to [__] around outside of his relationship?
If he's really willing if they have a relationship where he can
fly out and he can go on dates with these people and he could
like there's something I heard I think earlier on that he talks
about getting a cat with somebody. It's like that seems like
a long-term committed thing and if you have no intention of doing
that, that's crossing the line for me. I think that's fuck- I
think I don't think you should do that as somebody with a huge
profile like Sykkuno. Like that's insane to do that, right? To
go and like totally lie to a woman and pretend that you're going
to be like moving in with her moving in with you and you have
like no intention of doing that? That's crazy. >> think
that Sykkuno was already taken. Otherwise, he would have said
something after she proposed a date. He'd ask, "Do they have
an aquarium? I'm a big fan of aquariums." She'd say, "There's
Artis in Amsterdam. Could make it a date, you know, to make up
for Valentine's." He'd only reply with, "A what? Lol." continuing
on with his innocent persona, but he'd never say, "Oh, no, actually
wait, wait, like I want to meet up as friends. I'm I'm actually
in a relationship." Not once. The next section would be titled
making plans to meet me in person. So, bear in mind, this was
the next day, okay? The 16th of February. They had started talking
on the 15th. He followed her on the 14th. The document would
say, "In this two-hour Discord gaming call, the same day as our
first conversation, Sykkuno made plans to meet me IRL. It was
set to be the same weekend as Dokomi 2026 since he was flying
over anyway to attend TwitchCon EU. Going to the aquarium would
be our first date. I also learned that there is a 15-year
age gap between us." Right, so look, I personally spoke to the
victim about this. I asked like would that usually have been
like a red flag or a turn-off? She said yes, but the thing is,
this is Sykkuno we're talking about here, right? So, she made
an exception. I'm sorry. This is If he was up front about it,
you don't get to use this one against him. It sounds like he's
up front about it. Now, it's a little bit after you guys have
talked a bit, but I I wouldn't even be shocked if I just go Sykkuno
Like I see literally June 4th, 1991. It's right there. If you
can Google this super easily, I don't think you have any right
to be he's like a big content creator who you're a friend who
a fan You had to know he was at least 30, right? So, in the intro
of this document, she used to watch him in high school. She genuinely
looked up to him. To say that she was starstruck was an understatement,
and that's exactly what he was counting on. Now, while keeping
that 15-year age gap in mind, this next section definitely hits
different. It's titled making plans to move in together. These
messages would be on the 17th of February, two days after they
started talking. It would say, "With Sykkuno, our relationship
moved so incredibly fast it almost felt like a dream. It was
like you could make anything I wanted happen. And as someone
as prolific and successful as him, I had no reason to doubt anything
he said to me. These screenshots show that Sykkuno and I were
intending to adopt a cat and have me possibly move into his house.
I told him we couldn't get a cat yet due to me not being a US
citizen and possibly having visa issues. Keep in mind, this conversation
happened two days after the first conversation." The idea that
you're like inviting them to move in with you, I think that's
starting to give enough of a vibe of like, "Hey, I'm looking
for something committed with just you." without like clarifying
any of it, that it starts to feel quite manipulative to me. That's
where that's the line where I'm like, "Oh, this moves from being
like whatever whatever you just got you just wanted to [__]
it's whatever." And then it starts to feel quite manipulative
if he's talking about her moving in with him without letting
it slip that he's in another relationship cuz at that point moving
in together, you got to discuss what the relationship is, right?
Is she talking about wanting to move to America
is he like going to offer her like a temporary place to stay
for a little >> So, they start discussing the prospect
of getting a cat. Mal would say, "I mean, if I'm there anyways,
we'll have to think of a name now." To which Sykkuno would say,
"Yeah, but I don't know if I can take care of it myself." Mal
would say, "Or we're just going to name it cat." He'd say, "You'll
have to stay to help take care of it, lol." To which she'd say,
"I'm okay with that. Though, I don't know how that would work
with me staying there. I can't stay forever either, you know,
cuz I'm not an American citizen and I'll also probably have to
go back as well cuz I mean, I hope at least that I can go back
to studying at Yeah, this feels manipulative now. end of this
year. And like in general, everything is so expensive." And then
he'd say, "Oh yeah, that's true. Okay, maybe we can get a cat
together another time then. Besides, what if you already have
a cat?" To which she'd say, "Yeah, but they're my dad's. Also,
did you finally order Like that's that starts to get like manipulative.
Now you're trying to do the prospect of like this seems pretty
aggressively trying to use the prospect of like a long-term relationship
to [__] I'm I'm assuming that he's still with his
girlfriend this whole time, which I I haven't seen a lot of evidence
of that. I'm guessing we'll get that in the call. food?" And
he'd say, "Oh, I see. So, you wouldn't have to bring them if
you just moved somewhere." To which she'd say, "No, I guess not
though. I'd miss them so much, so I'd definitely have to get
new pets." So, apparently a couple days after speaking to each
other, Sykkuno's out here discussing getting a pet together,
taking care of it, raising it together, and looking into the
possibility of her maybe moving in together with him one day.
This was as he was sharing a home with his girlfriend.
The next section would be titled lying about being s- Now, all
this would be rough. >> single and dating history. In this
screenshot, Sykkuno said he has only ever had one relationship,
his Okay, now he's just overtly lying. Yeah, this is scummy.
Uh-oh.
Hey, listen, buddy. I took your side to this whole thing. If
you had a girlfriend like a committed relationship for a long
period of time, you are a piece of [__]
You are a total piece of [__] if you're doing this.
This is crazy. >> life. I would eventually find out that
that was a lie and that he had been dating and living in the
same house as his girlfriend for years and that I was not the
only girl on the internet that he spoke to on a daily basis.
So, here we can see DMs of them discussing this topic. Mal would
say, "I mean, you've been in relationships before. It's not like
it's your first relationship." referencing what they might potentially
have going on. To which he'd reply with, "I don't know, lol.
I've only like actually dated someone once and they broke up
with me, so yeah, I think I'm just not very good, so it's probably
just a me issue." To which she'd say, "Did you like never do
anything for your ex like at all?" To which he'd say, "I mean,
I think I did. I don't think she thought I did, so yeah. But
I mean, everyone has their own way of what they want, so it's
important to be like, are you getting what you want? And if you're
not, I totally understand." Mal, of course, would want to inquire
as to
Yeah, this is right. >> what he was saying. Like what do
you mean you think you did? Like like like what? But he'd never
specify and he'd always keep it vague, keeping up this persona
that he crafted, the one that was allergic to love, that had
no idea like what was going on with women. This would lead us
right into the next section titled
"We texted every single day." And these interactions would be
charged with flirting and suggestive topics. I would send him
suggestive pictures and audios, and he would confirm that he
touched himself to them. Additionally, he'd always act flustered
keeping up the illusion of his on-stream innocent persona. He'd
also regularly talk about date ideas and things we'd like to
do together in the future when we'd meet up IRL. Topics that
are usually discussed between two adults who are clearly romantically
interested in each other. On top of texting, we also called almost
every single day. Even after he'd stream for over 8 hours, we'd
talk and play games regularly. One thing I'd noticed is that
every time we called and when he spoke, he'd be whispering and
never fully use his voice. His excuse was that it's because he
was tired after a long stream, and I didn't really find that
to be suspicious. Using your voice for 8 hours in a row does
exhaust it after all. I now realize that he was quiet because
his girlfriend lived with him and he didn't want her to hear.
So, in this first set of DMs we can see them discussing things
to watch together. Sykkuno is saying, "Let's watch something."
Mal would say, "We should." He would say, "Let's watch a cook
Netflix dating show cuz those are funny or both." And Mal would
say, "We should." And "Do you also want to play games like Helldivers
or Overwatch or etc." In the next image we can see them discussing
the spicy audio that she sent him at some point. He'd say, "You
do too." She would say, "Yeah, like in that audio recording I
sent you?" To which he would act flustered over and say, "Huh?
Oh my god. Well, yes, you really sounded cute in that, too."
To which she would say, "Did you ever re-listen to it or only
that once?" In the next screenshot we can see them discussing
going on a gym date. Bro, you ever re-listen to it or only that
once? No response
to that. No response. He just He just totally don't know while
this woman
He sent him some audio of something, okay? Spicy audio. >> him
how much she enjoyed And he just didn't respond. Oh.
I She would have noticed that. That's a rough one, man. >> was
going to work out at the gym and so Sykkuno would inquire about
what a gym date looks like. This is when they discuss it more.
In the next two set of DMs we can see them talking about more
spicy topics. Mal would say, "You get flustered so easily." And
then Sykkuno would say, "Because I'm not I've never done like
this kind of thing before, lol." To which she would say,
Anglerfish, dude. Anglerfish.
Uh
this is This guy is the most feminine guy I've ever met. Women
do this. Women do this whole thing where they fake being like
more chaste than they are because they think it's what guys want,
right? This is like a very female-coded
way of flirting.
It's totally female-coded. Oh my god, I've just never done this
with anybody. I've never really dated anybody. I've just never
done this with anybody else. Oh my god. I guess maybe I did touch
my a little bit. Dude, I have it. And you don't like it? He'd
continue saying which is crazy cuz I'm older than you but like
I haven't really dated much, so. And then Mal would say, "So,
you have me now." He'd reply with, "My XP bar is low, but no,
I do it. I've never gotten something like this before. Yes, I
like it. It's so good. I can't wait to use it later." As in "I
can't wait to grill my sausage to it later." Whatever Dude, no
[__] To which she would reply with, "You know, I've
kind of wondered if you've ever touched yourself while watching
what I sent you." To which he'd say, "What? Why would you wonder
that?" She'd say, "Well, cuz there's The mind-blown the mind-blown
moment. What?
Where's the Where's the boar the the mind-blown boar, okay?
Where is it? Where is it? OH MY GOD.
WAIT. WHAT? OH MY GOD. WHY WOULD YOU WONDER THAT? WHY WOULD YOU
ASK IF I'M WHY WOULD YOU ASK IF I GOT OFF TO THOSE NEWS you sent
me? OH MY GOD. OH WHY? WHY WOULD YOU ASK? WHY you want to know
that?
What? Dude, it's
Yeah, that's crazy. >> spicy pictures and videos. Of course
I wonder if you put them to use. And then he'd say, "I'll definitely
put this one to use." She'd say, "So, you've never done so before?"
And then he would say, "Maybe" in all caps with a flustered sweating
emoji. This is when she'd put her foot down and say, "I want
a yes or no." And then he would say, "Yes, of course I have.
How could I not?" Overall, these DMs were a balance of spicy
and wholesome, just like what you'd expect when two people are
romantically interested in each other, saying good night to each
other, inquiring on their health. Did you off to that picture
I sent? Yes or Yes or no? Yes or no? Did you off to that picture
I sent you? Just a yes or no. A simple yes or no. Did you Did
you grip your [__] to that picture I sent you?
Overall, these DMs were a balance of spicy and wholesome, just
like what you'd expect when two people are romantically interested
in each other, saying good night to each other, inquiring on
their health. He'd compliment her on her appearance. She'd say,
"I love getting compliments from you. Good morning, handsome.
What are you up to?" But this romantic interest wouldn't just
be expressed with words. No, for Sykkuno, he'd make sure to express
it financially, too. This is what would lead us to the next section
titled "Sugar Daddy".
This guy
the via being a paypig. That is insane. Bro, I'm about You're
about to push me into some think before you sleep [__]
right now. This guy really abuse The abuse really ratcheted up
when he started sending me hundreds of dollars. No, stop. >> months
later, Sykkuno would randomly ask for my PayPal account in DMs.
He'd then waste no time in sending me money unprompted, something
that I'd later realize was simply a behavioral pattern that he'd
employ with women he'd express interest in. I want to reiterate
that I have never asked him for his money and he did this of
his own volition. He bought me both a gym jacket, linked below,
and Resident Evil 9 because I had expressed interest in that
game.
And Pokimane wondered, okay? Pokimane pondered She pondered for
a second, "Why aren't guys nice anymore? Why aren't guys nice
anymore?" Cuz you're going to Google Doc made if you buy women
Can't give these women [__] Oh my god. >> Here we
can see two payments. The first one sent on the 20th of February
2026, 81 euros, and the second one being 200 euros on the 5th
of March 2026. The sender was the business, Sykkuno. He'd innocently
ask for a PayPal username on the 20th of February. He'd start
off the conversation with, "Ah, you still aren't asleep, either?"
To which she'd say, "I fell asleep while Wait, did she say no
to this? What's What's your PayPal so I can buy you games later?
And then she sent him the PayPal and then he bought her games.
Bro. woke up again cuz I'm having trouble sleeping. He would
then say, "Oh, well, good morning. And what's your PayPal so
I can buy you games later?" She'd say, "Huh? Straight to the
point. Jesus. I need to update my email to my PayPal cuz it's
my old name from before I rebranded." So, up until this point,
this was Mal's experience with Sykkuno. The next section is titled
"A Calculated Pattern of Love Bombing and Manipulation". Oh,
boy. And this is where we talk about Elfilia's side of the story.
The document would say, "After speaking to Elfilia a few days
ago, we were able to corroborate our experiences with Sykkuno
and learned that we were both victims of this. We had no idea
that he was talking to both of us at the same time. Sykkuno is
known to send hundreds of dollars to the girls he wants to get
involved with. This screenshot is from when he took my friend
Elfilia to Paris during the 2025 TFT tournament. Along with sending
her 500 euros to help her move into her new apartment. You can
clearly see that this was sent from his business email's PayPal
account. So, unlike the other image that was supplied by Mal,
here we can clearly see this is
sending her all this money, a substantial amount, around 1,550
euros, all under his business email. Here are the DMs in which
we can see that he offered to pay for her flight to TFT Paris
as well as all the food and hotel fees there, pretty much taking
care of her financially during the entire trip. So, this starts
off as far back as April 2025 with Sykkuno telling Elfilia, 'I'm
probably going to Paris later this year for sure. I'm not sure
on TwitchCon yet. I'm afraid I don't know enough people.' He'd
say, "You should come to Paris when I go to it. Is it close?"
To which she'd say, "Paris is pretty easy to go to, yes, since
it's in the European Union." He'd say, "You better hang out then
when I go there." She'd reply with, "I'll have to see cuz I know
nothing and no one there and it's expensive." To which he would
say, "I'll pay for it. Don't worry." She'd say, "Woah, really?
You do that?" And then he'd say, "Yeah, of course. And all the
food." She'd of course be ecstatic about this and say, "You'd
have to deal with my annoying ass, though." And he would say,
"But you got to choose places to eat, like the restaurants."
And she'd say, "Deal." This brings us to the next section titled
"Elfilia's Experience". Elfilia would talk to Sykkuno on and
off for the span of five years. During that time, she had absolutely
no idea that he had a girlfriend in the five years that she had
known him and on and off flirted with him. Anytime she would
bring up the topic of his love life, he would give the response
of playing too many games and not going out enough to meet women
to date. So, in this next set of DMs we can see Elfilia saying,
"Also, I have a question for you. Why are you single? Like, how?"
To which he'd say, "Huh? That's a crazy question, lol. I think
it's a combination of like playing too many games." To which
he'd say, "Why crazy? Why is it a crazy question?" The guy was
desired by anyone. Even after his viewership had fallen down
a little bit, he could still DM any woman and get them to date
him. It didn't make sense. The document would say, "Same calculated
behavior and patterns, using his nerdy gamer boy facade to lure
women Man, I It's weird cuz I don't think calling I don't know
if predator is appropriate. There's probably some appropriate
name for this. What I would say is I've got no problem with them
going like you lie to women pretty like pretty much pathologically
and publishing the lies. I've got like no issue with that at
all. Has the nerdy gamer facade ever worked on women? Well, no,
this works. This specific thing
that he does works.
But it's cuz it's like a fantasy. He's just being a He's literally
a character, like a caricature of something they're trying to
use. He's He's being something that doesn't exist. He's like
intentionally doing something that doesn't exist. In this next
set of DMs, Elfilia would be saying, "You're cute. You're this
sweet to all girls or am I just lucky?" To which he'd say, "What?
Lol. Only to the ones I think are cool." So, as we can see, Elfilia
is just starstruck. She can't believe this. She feels so lucky
that Sykkuno, the guy who's desired by everyone, is giving her
attention out of anyone else in the world. This is the effect
he had on people and he knew this. And just like with Mal, he
would follow her personal Instagram with his official Sykkuno
Instagram page. It's genuinely like a déjà vu to what he did
with Mal. Like, it's the same patterns. The guy had a playbook
and he knew how to put it to use. The document would continue,
"Here is proof that Sykkuno was in Paris for the TFT event around
this time, too, directly from his Twitter." So, here you can
see this was posted around the 13th of December 2025 when he
was in Paris. In this first tweet on the left, we can see him
taking an image Oh, no.
Oh, no. Lily met one of the victims. >> LilyPichu who was
also there, as well as him retweeting one of TFT's tweets saying,
"Ultimate bragging rights have been secured at the TFT Paris
Open." This is them announcing that Sykkuno's team had won, confirming
that he was indeed there. The next page of the document would
show us a set of DMs between Sykkuno and Elfilia. The date would
be the 3rd of March, 2026. So, this would be 3 months after they
had met up and hooked up. And this would be as he was talking
with Mal. He'd say, "Oh my god, I was playing World of Warcraft.
I saw this player. It reminded me of you." It's because that
player had a similar-looking name. She'd say, "Aw, you got reminded
of me? That's cute." To which he'd say, "Of course." "Oh, I was
going to ask, were you planning on going to like OffKai or anything
like that? That's a YouTuber Expo, right?" To which she would
say, "I wish, but unfortunately I can't. My rent is now 800 euros
per month, and I'm living fully off of my sav- Dude, you're just
like openly You're like, literally, I'll show up and [__]
you again if you just pay for it. That's I'm sorry. You're like,
I don't I don't get to travel, but listen, 800 euros, I'm I'm
cheap for this one. We've We've hooked up before. I know you're
not like a That's literally what that is, right? It's pretty
obvious. >> saving, so I canceled all my travels for the
year. The document would say, "To add even more salt to the wound,
after Elfilia's Paris trip, in 2 weeks after he had started talking
to me, saying things like how he wants to move in with me and
such, he would message Elfilia asking her if she'll be at OffKai."
This is proof that he'd be talking to more than one woman at
the same time, planning a hookup for every event he went to.
He was doing this while giving me the impression that he wanted
something long-term, and all while also having a girlfriend since
2021. Elfilia and I weren't friends until I found out that he
was cheating on his girlfriend. This is when we both got in contact
with each other and shared our stories. She deserves the world.
And then at the end of this DM chain, we can see Sykkuno saying,
"How was your day?" To which she would reply with, "Awful. Spent
the whole day crying. Crying right now. Why do some men cheat?
I'll never understand." The document points out that this is
ironic, seeing that Sykkuno is a cheater himself. But how is
it that he did this for years with no consequences? How is it
that there are many Elfilia's and Mals out there with no one
saying a thing? Well, they kind of did, which is what the next
section is all about. It's titled "Rumors and Broken Friendships."
As I mentioned in the intro, no one made a public statement before
because they never had sufficient evidence. Sykkuno would always
talk about the most explicit and sensitive topics in voice calls
or in person, never leaving a paper trail. This was all intentional.
Rumors still managed to spread. Many content creators, both big
and small, would vent to their friends about his behavior. Behind
the scenes for many, he'd be known as a predator who regularly
took advantage of smaller and or vulnerable content creators.
So, here we can see DMs between Elfilia and Sykkuno. She would
start this off with saying, "I don't know, he said he dislikes
you," referencing a friend of hers, "and that you only go for
girls that are small so you can manipulate
Dude, that's crazy. She's like literally calling out the pattern.
She's literally like, "Hey, this this other guy said this. I
wonder who this is" that's saying it. You only go for smaller
creators that you can like manipulate with your shy persona.
Yeah, we're we're seeing I I feel like there's just there's basically
enough evidence here to say this is true. with your shy persona.
Yet he is doing that to my friend right now." To which Sykkuno
would say, "Oh yeah, I mean, I don't think that's true, but I
guess people will say stuff randomly. I'm confused as to these
people who think I'm going for them. I haven't really done that.
But anyway, I'm sure it'll be fine. I mean, like I said before,
people who know me will know me, and I guess he just dislikes
me, which is totally fine." She'd say, "Exactly. He did say the
only reason you haven't gotten called out is because you go after
small creators, and they'll never expose you. If you ever need
proof of anything, I have receipts, just in case he tries anything
funny." Sykkuno would say, "Oh, I feel like the way VTubers are,
they would love to try and expose bigger streamers. They love
drama." Dude, dude.
This is so This is so [__] up. You You don't even
get to Dude, hold on. Hold on. This is so rough because
This is so rough. She's literally going, "Huh, just so you know,
I'll like I'll give you all the Discord logs of this guy saying
it this about you."
And then you have the gall to write a to write a Google Doc
about that exact
thing that that person was warning you about. That's crazy. cheating.
This is what would lead us to the section, "Sykkuno's Girlfriend."
The coincidence that would lead me to finding out the truth about
Sykkuno happened last week. A popular male VTuber tried to slide
into my DMs to presumably get in my pants, and when I rejected
him, he immediately started to mention nasty rumors about Bao.
Out of concern for her, I reached out to a mod who then connected
me with Bao. The three of us struck Bao was a female VTuber,
right? struck up a conversation when I mentioned I was nervous
about a date I was going on. They asked me who it was. When I
said my date was with Sykkuno, they immediately told me not to
go on the date for my own personal safety. Bao told me that at
the end of March, Sykkuno's girlfriend reached out to her regarding
a controversial tweet Bao made last year in 2025. She asked Bao
if it was true that the tweet was about Sykkuno. Oh, hold on.
So, this tweet in ques- If you're an up-and-coming female content
creator with a small but growing audience, this Bao the whale,
yeah, okay. Small but growing audience,
and a much larger successful male content creator approaches
you out of nowhere and showers you with attention on stream,
in DMs, etc. Don't walk, run.
Oh, [__] The girlfriend messaged her and said, "Hey,
was this about my boyfriend?"
there's no way he was running this this much game and she had
no idea, right? There's no possible way.
That's That would be nuts if she was if if she was clueless about
it. Oh god, we're about to have the whole call and stuff, too?
Now I'm excited, man. Now I'm totally excited. In reality, though,
this was a subtweet directly referencing Sykkuno's behavior.
Because the document would continue, "They called," as in Bao
and Sykkuno's girlfriend, "and Bao explained to her that other
women had confided in her about similar experiences with him.
She described a pattern of behavior where he targeted small female
content creators and pressured them into having with him. Bao
then offered to connect her with these other victims so they
could share their experiences with her directly, as she felt
it was important to hear them first-hand. This was all discussed
during a Discord call." And so, here we can see a DM sent by
Sykkuno's girlfriend on March 24th, 2026 to Bao, saying, "Hey
Bao, I'm sorry to bother you with this, but I heard something
recently that was a bit concerning, and I thought I would just
come ask you about it. I heard that there was possibly an instance
of Sykkuno trying to get VTuber girls up to his hotel room to
drink with them, and that the tweet you made about being cautious
of large male streamers showering you with gifts and attention
was about him, in regards to him doing it to one of your friends."
You know, before we get back to the document, this actually reminds
me of this one tweet where an innocent fan came across Sykkuno
in the lobby of a hotel at 2:00 a.m. One can only wonder what
he was doing there, but Last night after walking a new friend
back to her hotel 2:00 a.m., we linked up with a guy who just
did the same thing. It took the like 5 minutes into our walk
back for me to realize I was talking to the real Sykkuno, Lmao.
Interesting way to end Twitch Con, for sure.
THIS IS LIKE THE BURGER PLANET MOMENT, WHEN he's hanging out
when he's talking to Dr. Disrespect. THIS IS THE BURGER PLANET
MOMENT for Sykkuno.
He is just hanging out and some nosy fan wanders over, starts
recording, takes a picture. Sykkuno is like, "Hey, man."
Dude, you can tell this is what happens. White white 6'7 gigachad
gets photographed while he's cheating. He goes, "Delete that
[__] now. Get get the [__] out of here.
Don't film me again." This This guy goes, "Hey, Sykkuno, do you
want to take a selfie with me?" And Sykkuno is like, "Yeah, I
guess so. Yeah, I guess so." As you can see, rumors are very
easy to spread once you spot someone in a hotel lobby at 2:00
a.m. The document would continue, "Bao told me that 3 days before
I contacted her and her mod, Sykkuno and his girlfriend were
trying to reconcile after Sykkuno somehow managed to convince
her that it was all a huge misunderstanding.
She had no clue that I, as well as many other girls, still existed
in Sykkuno's romantic and life. Bao and her mod would put me
in a group chat with Sykkuno's girlfriend, where I would share
all the screenshots you see. She was rightfully horrified and
left the group chat because she couldn't stomach reading them."
As you can see, DMs in the group chat from Sykkuno's girlfriend,
saying, "I have lived with him for over 2 years. We have been
together since 2021. And on top of that, everything he's planning
with you are things we have planned together and talked about
Dude, I always feel like that is Is that
honest to god,
like almost territorial?
and have done. I'm sorry." At this point, I wouldn't be able
to imagine what I would feel if I was in Mal's shoes or anyone
else's shoes that Sykkuno had taken advantage of. In fact, I
mean, I can't imagine being his girlfriend, hearing these rumors
about someone I lived with in the same home, and finding out
about it this way, even after he managed to convince me that
him sleeping with someone back in December 2025 was a misunderstanding.
It's horrifying. This would all lead us to the final section
of this document, titled "To All of Sykkuno's Victims." Ever
since Sykkuno's viral breakout during the pandemic lockdowns
of 2020, when he played Among Us, he has always carefully curated
every aspect of his behavior on stream and with friends. An innocent,
romantically inexperienced boy failure who looks like an anime
character and sounds like one, too. This perfectly curated image
would attract a large audience of women, with a lot of them openly
professing how attracted they are to him. He soaked in the praise
and never sought to limit the most extreme aspects of his community
because it made him more desirable. He understood this, and would
use this curated image, as well as his legitimacy in the content
creation space, thanks to his followers and famous friends, to
seek out any attractive cosplayers and or content creators that
were small enough to be starstruck by his grand presence. It
would work I I think this is all The funny thing is, this is
all garbage. It's like, I I'm sorry. You can't be upset that
this clearly fake persona is clearly fake. You can be upset that
he like he like basically tries to say that he wants that he's
like in love with you, he wants to move in with you immediately,
when he's like lying about it, he has a girlfriend already. Right?
I would even give him leeway if he was just like a total loser
who who wanted to like who who loved people immediately and wanted
to move in with them, and didn't have a girlfriend. I'd like
give him the benefit of the doubt there, right? As long as he
wasn't doing it with every woman. But like the fact that there's
like a pattern of him doing it with multiple women, the fact
that there is
that he had a girlfriend the whole time, these are [__]
up. Like it it it is [__] up to do that when you're
a big content creator. I think you were you're playing on a lot
of different like tropes for women just to get in their pants
and
the only thing that's weird is is I wonder what happened when
like did none of these women call the bluff?
Like what's what's going on are they not calling the bluff for?
I wonder if dude, I wonder if it has like an an opposite psychological
effect. Like when he seems clingy and needy like that if they
like pull away.
Is he like is he like next level? Is he that next level that
he immediately gets like clingy and needy and they never ever
want it like he gets really clingy really needy and then they're
like you know, I don't mind you but maybe I'll I'll keep living
where I'm living. What these many women didn't know though is
that he'd always lie about the fact that he's single. That behind
the scenes he had a neglected and depressed girlfriend that he'd
been with since 2021 and who has lived with him since 2024 in
the same house. I implore the many other victims to come out
about their experiences with this predator. And I end this document
with a recording of Sykkuno in which he admits to everything,
especially with how he cheated on his girlfriend with my friend
and was intending to do that with me as well. For context, this
was shortly after I had messaged his girlfriend about his cheating.
30 minutes later he would ask if I was free for a call as his
girlfriend was crying downstairs. He somehow chose to prioritize
someone that he barely met two months ago. She's referring to
herself. I pointed this out during the call. Here's the link.
This whole recording is 17 minutes long and as the document stated
he pretty much admits to everything. Watch. Hello. Hello. Thomas.
So. Well. Well, um pretty much know most of it.
Yeah, like what? No, what? No, no, you can tell me.
Okay. Well.
I mean, that right there, the second the millisecond the call
starts that way, you're being recorded. Does this guy have no
survival instinct whatsoever?
So you got zero survival instinct at
no, you tell me what you did. Yeah, you're recording me. Yeah,
I can't have this call.
Absolutely no survival instinct, man. This is this is wild.
About what? You have to speak up a little bit. My mic's cutting
out.
Sorry. Always happens. Not being single and I just wanted to
>> I I did not think it was going to be this bad. I I always
assume people are like way way way blowing things out of proportion
when they say things like it sounded like he was like hiding
when he was talking to me. If this is how he sounded most of
the time, yeah, this is like this is literally Anne Frank trying
not to get caught. There's people inspecting in the actual house
on the first level and she's like trying to talk to somebody
in the in the attic right now. Like what are we doing? >> Tell
you how it happened. You you're still going to have to speak
up a little bit by the way. You're still cutting out a lot.
Sorry. You know how I talk quietly. Um Yeah, but you never talked
this quietly.
I'm sad.
Uh it's the actions of your well, it's the consequence of your
own actions, I
I know. Mhm. Oh god.
He's got to dodge. He's got to dodge, buddy. Oh god, the voice
calls must be
Oh my god, that accent is terrible.
>> I was in a very happy relationship.
Doesn't sound like it, but sure.
I'll let me finish. >> Bro, what is she
what is happening in the background? Listen what is that that's
liquid sound? It sounds like she's putting lotion on or some
[__] Doesn't sound like it, but sure.
I'll let me finish. Uh-huh, continue. I was in a very happy relationship
a long >> Dude, it is lotion. It is lotion. You just heard
it. You just heard it squirted out. Listen.
I'll let me finish. Uh-huh, continue. >> I was in a very
happy relationship a long time ago. A long time ago. Or like
2021? I don't know the exact time, honestly, but long time ago.
Then it got a lot less
How so? I don't fully know. She just stopped hanging out with
me that much
Stopped hanging out with you? She lives with you. Yeah, I mean
Oh. You're going to have to speak up. I can't hear a single sentence
that comes out of your mouth. You there? Dude, this is like this
is like
punished like actively being punished dog energy where he's got
like his snout down and he's trying not to make eye contact and
he's like very small bean
Sorry. Things were like not good and I just like
you know, uh
they hang out with me much.
Okay, I now the heat's coming back again. I I tried to take his
side this whole time and this guy is a total piece of [__]
All right, I
hate this guy and I knew I should hate this guy.
This is crazy.
It is it is >> 35 By the way, she's like 20 and he's 34.
She's 20 and he's 34.
And this is the energy. This is the
Bro. Here. Okay, I'm just asking cuz you were went quiet.
Anyway, so
I was very very happy and
at some point it wasn't so happy. Um I don't know exactly when,
but like we stopped spending time together.
done anything together for years. For what? I can't I couldn't
hear that
Uh I said we hadn't done anything together for like years and
I was just very sad and alone. Didn't feel wanted at all. This
is by the way a total lie when you realize he was doing this
with multiple women at the same time, right? He is trying to
get out of cheating on his girlfriend, which he's been doing
basically if you believe the other girl, the Elfin Leia girl,
basically since he got in that relationship he's been cheating
on her, right? And he is trying to make it sound like well, we
just didn't hang out with each other anymore. But we know you're
doing multi-hour phone calls to play video games with these women,
right? Buying them video games, buying them that workout coat.
And now you come in here and you're like I just felt really lonely
and I didn't know how to handle it. And I just like I just needed
some connection.
No, man, you just want to [__] This girl's hot. This
girl's hot as [__] You just want to [__]
her. Why do you this is such man. No. So you slept with Elfin
Paris.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Hold on.
Oh hold on. He knows he's caught. He knows he's totally caught
right here. He knows oh, it's over. He it's done. You are caught
and there is no way out. You slept with Elfin Paris. Elfin is
the other girl from the doc and I don't know if he had any idea
that she connected those dots yet or talked about any of the
other women,
Like he now he now has to know oh, like my is exposed entirely.
Yes. Dude, I'm sorry. Even if he didn't
like a high schooler, even if he didn't somebody under age, this
should be a total nuke. This guy should be done.
For the persona he built, this should be a kill shot. All right,
so full of [__] Slept with Elfin Paris. >> of
[__] Yeah.
And then you flirted with me and were telling me how you wanted
me to come visit you in Vegas and how you wanted to go on a date
and how you were serious about me.
And how you really meant and how you wanted to go get a cat together.
Yes. Yeah. Why? Why didn't you just break off the relationship
then? Because
because a combination of
remembering how it
Some part of me hoping it would go back to that. And well, obviously
it's not going to go back to that if you're
Lies, lies, lies, lies, just all lies.
Bro, this guy is so full of it, man. Cheating on her. It's only
going to get worse. I think that's really on you, bud. And I
know you're I'm not even joking.
I'm going to again just totally make this up, okay? This is totally
made up. He actually was experienced when he met his girl inexperienced
when he met his girlfriend when he started dating her or
And she is like not on the same level of attractiveness as all
these other women. All these other women are like hot hot. And
he knows he thinks he could do both at the same time. His girlfriend's
probably like V-Tuber artist, probably depressed, probably not
having a great time, doesn't really keep tabs on him and he can
kind of just like have her doing [__] with him and
for him on the side living together and then he can go out and
try to [__] all these hot women,
That's 100% what's going on here, man. You're smarter than that.
>> I mean, take your 34-year-old man, yes, you are. Stop
acting like you're a child.
Um don't think that's what I'm acting like, but I mean, you still
He's just cooking him. Cooking him totally. He is acting like
a child. >> you're not smart enough. You are. You're 34-year-old
man. You just chose to do it. You knew damn well in the back
of your head that it wasn't going to end up well. Yeah, but it's
complicated.
It's really not. Cheating is just bad. She doesn't >> I can't
wait until we get to the point where he's like
I'm just kind of like a piece of [__] and I don't
really know what to do about
gone so far. I don't know how to get back to being a good person
again. I I know that that's coming. I would bet I would bet a
lot of money that that's
You know it's coming. hasn't done anything to ask for it to be
cheated on. pretty cut and Yeah, but she
relied on me to take care of a lot of
And I still cared about her. Okay, that doesn't mean that
you do that because you wanted to, not because you
not because she was like holding it against you or forcing you
to. No. Exactly. So, there's still no excuse for you to cheat
on her.
I'm not saying there was one. Just explaining what happened.
The only reason why it happened is because you just chose to
do it. I don't know why you would decided to lie to me cuz you
know damn well that lying
is like a big thing I do not tolerate. As opposed to all those
people who are
Please just lie. Just lie to me. I don't need to tell I don't
need to know the
There's just
Okay, it's fine. I don't know why I'm nipping. Go off, queen.
Go off, queen. And I was fine about the Alfie thing because I
was like, "Okay, he didn't know me before that, right?" But then
I find out you've had a girlfriend this entire time. Do you realize
how [__] up that is?
Cuz not only were you cuz sure, you didn't delete Alfie on. Alfie
acknowledges that you didn't lead her on, right? Cuz I've talked
to Alfie. I'm friends with her.
I've been friends with her before I even met you.
She acknowledges that you didn't lead her on. You led me on though.
You did lead me on though.
You gave me all these fancy ass promises about "Oh, we're going
to go on a date when you come visit here." What, so you could
cheat on your girlfriend again?
So you could sleep with me so you could cheat on your girlfriend
again.
That wasn't
What were you intending with that? Well, I thought it was going
to uh
be over.
Be over what?
Like I thought that was going to be the end of that.
The end of what? My previous
You were you were going to break up with so you could date me
or >> Well, like I said, it'd been a long time where like
we hadn't spent time together and done anything in years. And
in my head I thought that was at some point be over. What? Dude,
this guy is
so unfathomably
like I This is like
the most I'm the victim behavior I've ever seen in my entire
life right now.
Like he's he's just assumed the
victim role in this conversation.
And I dude, it's so it's so off-putting to listen to. at some
point be over. What? I couldn't hear you.
I said I thought that meant that was going to like the end of
it. So you're already moving on before you even broke up with
Were you intending to break up with her or were you just waiting
for her to break up with you? No. I don't know. It's just a really
weird I just mix of like
I just want to understand this. So what what was your intention
with me? Like where where where was I in this whole thing? Like
were you intending to date me after her? Like were you intending
to just ditch
to go date me? I mean, I guess for me it felt like it was already
I mean, yeah, that's kind of what I was thinking.
You were thinking to just ditch her and then date me. What, were
you going to do the same thing to me? I'm sorry, but like you're
not really selling this whole relationship thing really well.
This is type of relationship she won't >> Fine. Not trying
to sell it. I can't tell. Dude, he's getting so hard. It's so
funny. Thank you for recording this. Okay, I'm sorry.
Uh Hemamal, queen, I'm so sorry that I talked about you. Okay,
I was not thankful enough for you recording this man's total
on on audio on this Discord call, okay? I was not thankful enough.
I talked [__] about your Dutch accent. I actually
think your Dutch accent is not that off-putting. It's not totally
disgusting. I don't think I can hear the fact that you put little
waffles on top of your coffee before eating them. I can't hear
that at all, okay? You're not even remotely
Aw, I'm sorry. But if anyone comes out dropping a doc on a guy
and uses love bombing anywhere near the anywhere in the accusations,
there's a 99% chance that her and all of her female friends are
legitimately
Uh I like I said, this guy's not going to prison, right? But
this is his persona. He is this nice guy persona and that's not
who he actually is.
Yeah, this is too bad. This is Bro, you
He's got so many opportunities to like make himself seem human.
And he just can't do it ever. It's
Very sad.
Why? Why why go through all this trouble? Because
didn't know how to uh Why? Why did I go through all this trouble?
That's a That's a good question. I really don't know where it
all began. I'm
having a hard time even putting my thoughts into words.
Dude, bro, I miss me with this occasion. What
I mean, for God's sake Dude, he just he just like stopped in
the middle of that. Hold on. Listen to this pause again.
didn't know how to uh
I mean, for God's sake
Yeah, he just he just froze. I didn't know how to is I
I didn't know how to The really the only thing why you even stayed
with her is because she Oh, she relied on me for a lot of things.
You couldn't afford to take care of her for a little bit before
she gets back on to her and like her
Like at least don't put her through the trouble of like telling
her like, "Oh, like I'm still going to be with you." Like telling
her that you're still her boyfriend
while actively cheating on her every single day. Yeah, I mean,
you're you're right. I should have just um said how I felt. Like
you could have just dead ass If if the only thing that you were
concerned about is the fact that she relied on you for things,
you could have just Every day? Uh most people and I think this
is
I there I like come in I I have different opinions on this on
different days. It feels like it's never a clear line to me.
some people do consider like any amount with another person to
be like full on cheating full stop. There is no question. And
I understand the betrayal feels similar.
There does feel like there's something else there. Like when
you actually somebody in person, it's like a different thing.
I'd still say like the cheating of of with somebody is still
like it is still cheating.
It's a slightly lesser offense in some
Um but it like I would have no problem with somebody who was
like, "Yeah, I found out they were another person. I I next them."
That I That's totally that totally makes sense to me. That's
totally fine with me. I just
I'm like I understand how also, you know, if somebody forgave
someone for someone else that especially when you like are Discord
people
I could almost understand letting that go if it wasn't like in
person and
It's manslaughter not murder. No, it's like it's like murder
two instead of murder one. It's it's still murder. It's still
bad. It's like it's also got all of the bad elements. Like the
same deceptions, the same like "Oh, I'm not willing to resolve
things in the relationship." It's like got all of the bad flags
as
It's just like somehow a little bit
There's like something
So sorry, people are like cheating when when Canadian caller
asked "Cheating every day?" What did he say this?
Did he say uh Was he like every day? Oh, I see. Every day I'm
back on Team Saki. I thought you were saying like every day as
in she was exaggerating. No, it probably was every day. He was
like different random women. I'm guessing.
supported her until she got back on to her feet. So she could
support herself, you know? It wasn't just that. Then what else?
Somehow hoping it would go back to how it used to be. Well, as
I've already told you, cheating is not going to make it go back
to how it used to be.
It's a lot easier to say that when It's the truth.
It's the harsh truth. Nothing is going to go back the same way
that it was if you're going to I had to [__] that
tight hot 19-year-old piece so that I had a chance for my relationship
to heal, okay? You don't understand. You don't understand. I
had to try to [__] my way through as many model-looking
Vtubers as I could because I needed my relationship to heal.
Yeah, I don't I don't think so, bro. I don't think so, little
bro. How the [__] you doing this half-crying voice
at this exact moment in time? I just had to I had to wreck that
tight 19-year-old
to try to save my relationship. No, you didn't. No, you didn't.
No, you didn't. Jesus Christ, man. I cheat on someone actively.
Yeah. Well, that's why I'm going to change. And You're going
to change what? Oh, is it
>> everything. What do you mean that's it?
Just going to change
Are you going to stay with her? Honestly to God, I feel like
the poor girl's been through enough. I don't think you should
have to to do sit there and keep doing this to her. You know
why and I think I should explain. Ominous much? Not ominous,
just the truth. Oh, he There's no way he reached out to her.
That's why he's not scared of recording, right? That's why he's
not scared of recording cuz he's reaching out to her.
I think that's what it is, right?
He's reaching out to her. That's what it sounds like. But you
know why and I think I should explain. Ominous much? As in he's
saying "I want to call and talk to you about this."
Oh, boy. >> I was in a group chat with her while you were
on stream.
this girl's absolutely distraught
because of the [__] that you've done to her. The
[__] that you've put her Like genuinely. Do you know
how much that [__] someone up? Pretty bad, man. >> Like
you already cheated on her once and she decided to trust you
still.
She decided to stay with you despite the fact that you already
had cheated on her and admitted to it. And what do you go do?
You go on to [__] Twitter and go find the next girl
to flirt with. Like I think anything honest to god, I'm not even
mad at this point. I'm just disappointed.
I'm really disappointed. Yeah, that's fair. Cuz
she's been crying to Bow about it.
Bow has been sitting there like comforting this girl, trying
to tell her, "Hey, maybe you should leave because this isn't
okay.
This really isn't okay.
You're putting this girl through mental strain every single day
that you continue to be with her.
While you're sitting there having fun playing with your friends.
Be so honest right now, Thomas.
Because she deserves better than that. Because you cannot sit
there and be like, "I love her." but do all this [__]
to her and continue to let her stay in that situation.
Well, one part of that wasn't true. Hey, don't say you don't
love her. That's [__] What? And
I think the feelings faded. Oh, you son OF A YOU SON OF A [__]
OH, that girl's
That poor V-Tuber artist girl is destroyed. What an [__]
What an [__]
He's like, okay. So, what he's trying to do, you understand what
he's trying to do right now, right? He is mentally
right now as we speak.
He's mentally visualizing, okay? And he's going, "Okay, how
cuz I If I Unless I misunderstood
he's not [__] this girl yet. And he's just He's trying
to think, "How do I save it? How do I save it? How do I make
it happen? How do I I'll say anything I can to make sure that
it still happens. How do I save it?" And that's what he's trying
to do. That's what he's thinking right now. He thinks he can
save it. And I guarantee he thinks he can save it cuz he saved
it with his girlfriend before. When he [__] around
and behind his girlfriend's back, he saved it before.
He thinks he can pull it off again.
I thought he hit No, he [__] the Alpha the Alpha
and Leia girl. That's who he had sex with. This girl, I believe
he's not actually had sex with this girl yet. I think you should
just let her go. I'll feel you. >> Instead of just sitting
her there wasting her time. Okay. Well,
>> And also, why'd you get on a call with me when she's
right now she's upset? I know she lives with you.
I already talked to her. You should be there to comfort her.
She's She's the one that you cheated on. No, I'm going to be
doing that. I just
wanted to settle this first. This is not settled. I'm You know
what's too much? She does. Dude, this is the worst part, right?
This is the worst part is these these women started coordinating.
So, now the whole thing that was saving it was that he had information
siloed, right? He had all the information siloed, but
now that they've started pulling their
he can't save it, okay?
Why are you talking to me? I know your girlfriend's crying right
now. I already had a group call with her today. I had a group
chat with her today while you were on your stream and just hung
out and and buddied around with your pals, okay? I know she was
crying. Beyond upset with you.
Like genuinely beyond upset with you. I
that's fine. By settled, I mean like that's that's it. Like
What's it?
Probably never talking He's I'm telling you, he's going to try
to make this
Now, the real question is how amenable is it to that is she?
Cuz she's I I would think given the call, she might actually
be amenable to that. That like, "Hey, maybe this will work out.
Maybe this could still work." But I think because the document
came out, I don't think so.
Like the call makes me think, "Oh, that's probably what he thinks
too. She's calling me or sorry, she's picking up the call. She's
not like furious with me enough to not pick up the call. I can
fix it. I can save it." Again? You and
Yes. Okay, there it is. There it is. I
What's it?
Probably never talking again. Oh, wait. Wait. Hold on. No, I
missed it. I missed it. I missed it. Yes. Like we're never talking
again. We're probably never talking again. It's over. Okay. Okay.
Sorry. I missed it. >> What? Why? Is that not why?
What is why? I'm still upset with you, but you didn't cheat on
me.
WHAT?
DUDE, NO.
THERE'S NO WAY.
YOU CAN STILL talk to me and be like make up for your actions.
Don't get me wrong cuz I always am there for second chances.
But I never will forgive you for cheating on her. That that's
That's all.
No shot. No shot.
Now, hold on. Hold on. What is the point of that? WHAT IS THE
POINT OF THAT? Why did she say that? And she left in the call.
She left in the call that she
Was she just Is she just like that sadistic that she wanted to
give him hope that she wasn't going to publish all of this? That
she wasn't going to go live and and put all this out in the into
the ether? Is that what she was doing here? She wanted to just
She wanted to have him totally blindsided by this when it got
published.
Cuz that's the only thing I can think of cuz as soon as you publish
it, it is over, right? No, he cuts her off. Okay, well, we'll
see.
Um There are a lot of girls that are upset with you, by the way.
Cuz Alphy's not the only one that has hit me up. Yeah, that sounds
like you've heard
Um Yeah, and you lied to me a lot about that, too. A lot.
Is that That's all. That's going to haunt my That's going to
haunt my nightmares.
Well, he didn't cheat on me.
How big was her roster again? Well, they got mad one of those.
Oh, he's back IN CHARACTER. HE'S GOT HIS CONFIDENCE BACK. HE'S
BACK IN CHARACTER. HE'S OUT OF LIKE VICTIM mode and he's back
in character.
I don't think I ever had one of those.
No shots. I mean, maybe not the same time, but
you sure do hop around.
All I care about right now is that It's okay. Keep me updated
on that. I don't know if that's a possibility.
You can keep me updated on how she's
You can keep me updated on when she moves out cuz I don't think
she should be living with you anymore. I don't think you need
me to do that. I mean, yeah, I care about her. I This is This
is just weird now. I care about her. I
am very scared that you're getting off on this in some way now.
You literally just said, "Well, you didn't cheat on me. I care
about her though. You need to let me know how she's doing. Tell
me about like just how much she's crying. Why don't you tell
me about like you know, if you could give me like a a a volume
in milliliters of like the tears that she's shed, that would
really help me.
>> She can do that.
Mhm, true. I'll just reach out to her
Yeah, I know. Just like go talk to her. She needs you right now.
Yeah, okay. Oh,
Bye, Thomas. Yeah, I do remember those squishy noises. >> Shortly after
the call, the last thing Mal would ever say to Sykkuno would
be, "I'm beyond disappointed in you." So, look, according to
Mal, there are countless other victims. It is completely up to
them on whether they want to come out with their side of the
story or not. For now though, we can confirm at least two different
people that were completely misled by him and as he cheated on
his girlfriend so comfortably. In those two instances, we can
see him also using the same playbook, the same tactics, sending
them money, making them feel special, following their personal
Instagram, wanting to meet A Sap to hook up, everything. And
I think one thing that personally struck me was how only 30 minutes
after his girlfriend found out about his cheating and probably
confronted him, he chose to run upstairs and prioritized Mal,
someone he met two months ago. There's a reason people say with
great power comes great responsibility because once you have
this power that Sykkuno possessed, you can so easily take advantage
of others. So, as a content creator, you have a very clear choice
and unfortunately, Sykkuno decided to be the worst person possible.
I wish all the victims in this travesty the absolute best and
I also in So, yeah, here's the thing. Can we see the end of the
document? Like that's the last DM she ever sent him, okay? So,
here's the Google Doc. You go to the very end. This was the last
thing I said to him. Now, why was that the last thing you said
to him? And it's now what, 6 days?
Did you
get blocked by him? That's the real question, right? Did you
get blocked by him? Did he block you for some reason?
Cuz if I swear to god, if he like tries to keep it together with
his girlfriend and he's like, "I'll block her and we'll stay
together." And then she gets blocked and then this document comes
out, that's going to look bad, man. That's going to look bad.
And by the way, this doesn't really help him with uh it doesn't
really help him look better. He looks bad no matter what happened
here, right? Like I think his his weird like lying [__]
that he's doing to all these women looks bad no matter what,
but it would make her look really bad, too. She'd look rough.
I'm not even a fan. Just want to call all of you guys a bunch
of for switching up on him over nothing major. It seems like
all he did was cheat. Nothing illegal was done. And they're trying
to paint him as something he isn't. Right? People, it's not just
cheating. It's lying. He is a He is a person who's going to use
his fame to go and lie to people and try to [__]
them
repeatedly and there is no problem with exposing that to the
world. Throw that out to the world. Say this guy's a lying degenerate
scumbag. Put it out there. Let everybody know.
I I'm almost behind the word predator. It's like right there.
Like that he he is doing something to like violate these women
in a way that isn't just like
If he was doing something else, if he was like if he was doing
something non-consensual, if he was meeting them in person and
like getting them like deliriously drunk or inebriated in some
way, right? But
but it didn't seem like that. That's the public predator to me.
Scumbag covers it just fine. Yeah, sure scumbag covers it just
fine.
I think predator implies like you would be in danger if you talk
to him. Beyond Beyond like emotional danger. You would have like
some something could happen that's beyond just like an emotional
risk that you would not want to happen. Also it is also antithetical
to his stream persona. Yes. Also that. Yeah, it's really really
rough trying to resolve the tension between the two. I was told
that Stail had a reaction to this. Let's see the Stail reaction.
"Sykuno guilty of being a player."
"Sykuno is guilty of the most obvious thing in the world, being
a player with a fake online personality, and that's it. He's
innocent of everything else. Sykuno got accused by some What
else was he accused of?
He's innocent of everything else. >> VTuber girls a being
some sort of Sykuno Weinstein who is was using his powerful connections
and fame to take advantage of smaller content creators. None
of that
Wait, he was using his fame to take advantage of small content
creators. We just allow for that as a society.
We literally just allow that for that as a society.
That's all.